auf dem truppenübungsplatz allentsteig
findet von 15 bis 26 juni 2015
die übung handwerk 15 erstatten unter
dem kommando der vierten
panzergrenadierbrigade üben 1200
soldaten und soldatinnen den schutz von
räumen verkehrswegen und objekten wie zb
öffentlichen gebäuden
die kampfgruppe 13 bestehen aus einer
aufklärungskampagne eine batterie
batterie eine ganze kompanie einer
kompanie führungsunterstützung kompanie
und einer unterstellten patrick
compagnie ag hat den auftrag die
ortschaft steinbach von illegalen griff
den zu säubern und die sicherheit und
ruhe in ordnung in steinbach
herzustellen
der heilungsverlauf ist wie geplant
erfolgt alle soldaten sind motiviert das
ziel wurde erreicht und es besteht somit
für heute kein bedarf diese aufgabe es
ist einer von sechs aufgaben den rahmen
der nächsten woche beziehe diese woche
bereits durchgeführt wurden
hierzu wieder ruhig